that is as good as those one DS yeah
yeah was that pentatonix pentatonix did
I do that they did like a 0 audio thing
in that an orchestra back them up is got
some American markets are backing them
up but all they were do is go data
better and then one getting ridiculously
high school oh my gosh my main video got
two billion views did it have text on
probably Star Wars it's hot you may have
seen it I'm gamespot com or anywhere
else on the Internet mm-hmm we've got
three star wars experts here Rob the
woodsman handlery Josh layers Shaw and
Andy NASA NASA baman doesn't I'm excited
a fur yeah what not over you for the
movie not about fun who's so still
playing battlefront play a little bit of
it yeah kind of wears off right yeah we
knew that yeah you that going in well
I'm you know I'm the way for the dlc uh
but I enjoyed all front a lot I mean
it's star wars game it's the best
sounding looking sours game I feel like
out is it I probably know that's crazy
that's got like the most graphics I'd
give you a most projects it's got 1080
it's got plenty of graphics got lots of
frames per second it's a lot of graphics
yeah but is it the best Star Wars game
no no no they are not by a long shot
then let's go damn through well Andy
balance yeah ball that title belongs to
the classic rebel assault and rebel
assault 20 really a nice little FMV
driven game on the PC back in the day
not expecting this to be the first yeah
we did not talk about this kid this and
won't for going off like you know at the
time these graphics were insane cuz it
was video you get back video right yeah
but do you think if I thousand top about
friends to stop that let's go down as
far as we can then let's take x-wing vs.
type yeah let's get into the window
really good one cycle that's that's
gotta be 1992-93 x-wing okay let's find
so x-wing Tie Fighters an x-wing vs. TIE
fighter that whole series was just
incredible because what it gave you was
a simulation experience of a type
fighter pilot in the next week pilot you
you
do the shield's you link your blasters
you do you power your engines you
freakin fly around and shoot dudes like
and not even the flying in battlefront
is as good as this like this is the best
fly so like you can a bit like this is
astonishing first space it's one of the
best so I good space simulator flying
games ever and you see uh this HUD might
be makes no sense but like you have your
shields there on the bottom left you can
decide if you want for your honor
fullback you can link your lasers there
you can see in the targeting reticle
there are linked fire so all four fire
at once or you can do a succession fire
you have torpedoes you have you can do
these epic dogfights where you're
chasing down yeah like fighting in 3d is
really hard to do right yeah yeah and
they back that oh yeah and but yeah and
back then when it was on 11 floppy disks
like this was really freaking that
speaking on with the next games because
these games are definitely like they
felt like they were ahead of the time
when they came out and when dark forces
came out in the mid 90s that also felt
like oh wow wait we're this is like a
first-person stuff star wars game where
I feel like like I'm shooting
stormtroopers I'm walking around these
environments and obviously this series
ended up you know your dark forces two
Jedi Knight and which then spawn the
sort of later Jedi Academy Jedi Outcast
sort of stuff but yeah these old games
any you guys play these ones oh crap out
of these games because when my dad went
to the software store the guy was like
we want to buy this it's like doom
really but better so do because it is
like its exact it's it's the same style
but like you shoot stormtroopers with
the blaster guns like from the movies
like it's insane like how as a kid you
played this and you were like instantly
drawn into this so so much and like
there's so many knots in the movies
there's thermal detonators there's crazy
swamp monsters you have the fighter
really hard there's like every
stormtrooper every Imperial and there's
like mon mothma you're like working for
my god how much good stuff in these
games oh and they're really hard as well
yes like not easy it's no joke and they
were so much more varied than doom at
the time like doom was like go here and
push the eggs that you're done these
like had missions and stuff yeah well
like back then three years in you know
first-person design was
like a lifetime you know yeah this was
like 1995 and then think it was 99 when
the dark forces to Jeddah and I came out
and then we had a resurgence with the
you know the calc Tarn Jedi Outcast Jedi
Academy James and though it's incredible
to which it's even hard to remember that
they were sort of rebirths if those old
ones those games were so brilliant on
their own ride like third person LAN LAN
party gentleman jellified a kidding me
like when they my life in a star wars
final I used to love that [ __ ] when they
introduced the lightsaber into those
games you were like how's this gonna
work oh my god they nailed it perfect
and you wrote and selling you have all
the power to push let's throw it you
like in you and battle for when you
become yeah the hero whatever and you're
like Luke and you push attack and you
like you have no control like you're
just lunging forward with your life
saver these you had like epic control
you jump you do flips you like nail
stuff you throw it and you have tools
and other like it was so [ __ ] good
like I'm like at a LAN party there was
nothing better than doing things and
like you someone would fire a rocket and
you're just like force push it back and
I'm like really some was in those games
back then was like incredible and now in
battlefront you play as like you play as
Luke invader and it's you just feel dumb
right like you feel so does like this
new toys like yeah I Joshua when you
think about good Star Wars games what
you think of uh well there was a shadow
of the Empire right that's what's called
i always forget the name than 60 phone
though oh yes I remember like the
morning i got the n64 me my dad like
spent hours trying to figure out how to
beat the first level we take out the
8080 cuz I didn't know about the tow
cable because it's the first time I've
ever held an n64 controller and
everything yeah [ __ ] is this yeah what
is he like wait I don't hold with which
handles do I use where's Marcos in my
mind well wait so we're actually saying
good well oh no legitimately that's what
we're saying is that this game had the
most bizarre cheat code or in ever
created I know I Darren's thought I was
mentally ill when I because what you had
to do was hold down every single button
on the 64 controller for how long uh you
had to hold it home down on the border
right you like doing in the pressmen in
order I don't remember
sounds like some like the urban myth ya
know but whoever did it was like let's
just make people look as dumb as
possible and then you had to basically
move the stick halfway to the left
halfway to the right to the left half of
the right like four times so at this
point you're like either your brother
had to do it this is what I made my
brother do he wasn't allowed to play
with demonstration here yeah so or I
would do this or I would take the
controller now put it in my mouth and
use my lip as a half way guard and do
this and do this four or five times and
yeah and someone would come in the room
be like what die how are you are you
fellating that again I want to be a
whopper which is like you could use a
[ __ ] but we know is the guy that beat up
Luke an empire strikes back it's a big
like furry white bear you could be as
him you could spawn them I or just be as
play as one but the whole thing was then
the end you could play his Malema Falcon
TIE fighter you get all these cool cause
that was a that was like so think about
that game is there so many modes like it
starts out flying a ship and then it
goes first person shooter right and then
it goes there's like turn modes when
you're riding in a ship the outrider
yeah like good variety yeah speaking of
Nintendo consoles did you guys play the
Star Wars or super star wars games on
the NES no I didn't have any is a lot of
people like sure that's gonna talk about
that as well let us know in the comments
had an any yeah actually just came out
of his foot all those the whole dynamic
catching I'm a plated a friend's house
cool but back in was read to can you buy
those separately from from my foot for
battlefront yeah no I'm not sure oh did
it just come out OH separate it was like
weeks I don't it's like four games from
like that its package I'm sure how much
things like 10 bucks iron anyone here
played republic commando no goddamn with
icing snob back then that was it that
was on PC I don't know it was definitely
played it on pc this was the first
person like it was basically hit like
halo ODST oh yeah but with Boba Fett
would put soldier I guess de la Marie
stormtroopers they're like republic come
out so they're kind of like the next
layer right it was like a four player oh
Jesus here's a video I made years ago oh
yeah that was a 440
add you and cleared like people to [ __ ]
everybody here we are yeah yeah you were
three other piranhas and Isis and the
coolest thing was if you kill somebody
up front you get blood on your visor and
it would [ __ ] clean like a laser
let's go [ __ ] blood off your front of
your face ok so this is pepper mrs.
Palmer so you see some yeah that dude
there you stop wait what's up you can
stop your own guys this looks like
Daniel this is like an yeah definitely
Daniel think they're blowing is yeah
this guy I don't usually play it again
killing every single stormtrooper in it
but yeah I see look that is cool tremely
distract is like it was alright cool and
that guess one of the biggest pc games
you want to talk about Star Wars pc
games though like to do her probably
Andy you played a bunch of that okay
well that was like the best game I
played like I'm sure if I go back to it
now I'll see through a lot of it but
back then dude not only was it this
sprawling RPG with like amazing
decisions yeah a great plot twist yeah
but it was like the precursor to mass
effect because you're traveling my
galaxy on this ship you have companions
basically talking to all them doing
quests for them going to all these
different locations doing like quests on
those locations like it was so epic and
was all in it was like Star Wars right
it was totally started your lightsaber
the combat system was like a little bit
weird because it was like straight-up
RPG yeah like yeah queue up stuff and
cube and but it was cool um but yeah it
was like basically mass effect before
they decided to just make their own
universe and this was set like it was
like in some it was like before the
super before any other like Star Wars
stuff right so you kind of felt like
yeah good you know Greg Kathryn liked it
too I was like you're rubbing shoulders
with [ __ ] neo film actors and knowing
that you could not much effect over the
world like you didn't know what's gonna
happen yeah that's another big thing
that turned me off about battlefront is
like yellow the main heroes doing it
well like shadow the Empire you are like
Han Solo's friends royce basically is
twin but like you're like daddy's are
with your own smuggler ship in your own
to bacha yeah it's funny I actually just
just skimmed through shadows of the
empire because I forgot like what was
actually a story about and it's so cool
that funny how they just
took just plot elements you know I mean
of the movies and then just kind of fill
in the gap like already there's just
dash Rendar guy just you know hanging
out with Luke and Leia like he's part of
the gang am I right in saying that at
literally every game we've talked about
today has been stripped out of the Star
Wars lore yes yeah I mean everything has
once like Disney bottom the only things
that remain canon are like all the
movies and those kids cartoon series
wait even the three even the Lucas's my
prequels are chemicals so the cannon
yeah yeah so it's those six movies and
then like everything they make now so
any new book or any new comic any new
clone wars the shower with rebels so
kala Katara doesn't exist the Star Wars
anymore that's like pressing but the
Republic commandos don't wipe blood
officer faces it's something kind of
cute where they call them legends so now
it's almost like in this universe it's
kind of like a little bit of like maybe
their stories people tell each other or
something rather than actual history
missed always oh thank you remember how
kotor yes basically like legitimize
going light and dark side because it was
RPG you choose like oh yeah like Paragon
renegade people kind of yeah they're
like oh there's no gray area but it's
like in that one it was like dark side
lights all right i totally made I think
I know your answer them let's go through
everyone watch your favorite star wars
game ever made rebel assault no song no
no no nice it would probably one or two
I never played two it came in like a
year later yeah that's yeah but I I just
heard the ending was god-awful and
everything was terrible all right or
what I guess was up in Josh Shaw a rogue
squadron on gamecube oh okay thank you
yeah I like cuz you have the Bering in
that one and there's like this like
shield that would come down to highlight
enemy ships I don't know it just felt
like you're really liking controller one
of those things however no buttons and
stuff God the best thing I just want a
gamecube so i can just put a disc in
there make a good death yeah little
little tiny little hole in the middle
east go Don there's like mini discs look
good and I had a handle you could just
pick it again everybody's I remember cuz
like the whole reason to get a ps2 is
also DVD we couldn't fit a DVD in it Rob
handlery favorite star wars video game
Rogue Squadron 64
hey and it's one of you were mentioning
like thai fighter and next week all
those yeah like and where I think this
movie is getting me really excited was
because I did read a bunch of books
growing up but that game worked me so
well as a kid maybe so excited because
it was like x-wings and ships in
atmospheric land all right right so when
you see the trailer for sign and it's an
x-wing booking across the water causing
the water to steam up and ripple it's
like uh you know you just get rogue
squadron's and it's like oh yeah wedgies
yeah you have Wedge Antilles release
these guiding you through yeah yeah
these like background characters that
were so sick like and there was a Luke's
copilot like dak right all right oh yeah
dak before he died in the battle of hoth
and stuff all these like really cool all
the Rogue Squadron characters what's the
one game nobody mentioned Oh women
probably miss a fuckload like for help i
really like little disappointed we are
of that movie like that game was awesome
I mean look it was so i can do you a
boost impression do it you do some all
those engines though dude objective of
dirty no again Hodges in the UH i began
edible alright i also love that nobody
with no one ever mentioned any of the
numerous film tie-in games that came out
yeah that series which almost
ubiquitously sucks i'm sure why don't
you believe in their problem on davis I
worked in retail when they brought out
like some of the yeah the ones for like
the prequels and they won every platform
like there was like seven different
version to do what about like Disney
infinity that's not working no disney
infinity three point oh yeah i mean
that's like jack skellington xin your
Star Wars me it's like those I don't
know I didn't watch those kids shows but
it's kind of cool if you had a kid but I
can't play Star Wars stuff but yeah sup
well not really for me yeah it'd be cool
to get your kid Stowers toys that aren't
like super nice LEGO sets that I'm
keeping I like it and Jenna thank you
come on up coming on talking all about
Star Wars that films coming out pretty
soon that game done came out last week
so to keep up until
when all of your hot star wars video
game and film news stay tuned in case of
allcom let us know in the comments what
your favorite Star Wars video game is
and why we are wrong